des informations tirées de son
expérience au groupe de sécurité de la
présidence de la république
si vous le voulez monsieur le préfet
vous pourriez mais ça n'est pas une
obligation commencer cette audition par
un petit propos liminaire avant que nos
rapporteur puis nos collègues vous pose
des questions précises mais avant cela
je me dois de vous rappeler comme je lé
fais pour toutes les personnalités
auditionnées qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission des lois doté
des prérogatives d'une commission
denquête serait passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amande et je dois vous inviter à
prêter serment en disant toute la vérité
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je le
jure je le jure
merci monsieur le préfet vous avez la
parole merci bonjour à toutes et à tous
vous avez souhaité même auditionné dans
le cadre de mes fonctions passées de
chef du groupe de sécurité du président
de la république ne 2007 à 2012
mais je souhaite revenir sur ce qui a pu
me conduire l'expérience qui a pu me
conduire à ce poste auparavant
donc j'étais officier de police pendant
21 ans de 1986 à 2007 puis en 2007 j'ai
été nommé sous préfet et en 2010 j'ai
été nommé préfet je suis donc depuis le
1er avril préfet en disponibilité à ma
demande
comme vous venez de le dire les
fonctions que j'ai pu occuper
j'ai rejoint le cercle un peu privé de
la sécurité rapprochée en 2002 je
rejoins à l'époque le service qui
s'appelait service des voyages officiels
ce service est devenu le service de
protection des hautes personnalités par
la suite et enfin le service de la
protection aujourd'hui
en 1981 12 pardon j'ai dit en 2002 je
crois en 1992 lorsque j'ai rejoint ce ce
service j'ai été affecté à la sécurité
des personnalités étrangères sur notre
territoire
puis en 1993 j'ai rejoint la sécurité du
premier ministre monsieur edouard
balladur alors qu'il était donc chef du
gouvernement en période de cohabitation
et candidat à l'élection présidentielle
ensuite en 2000 2002 en 1997
je rejoins la sécurité de monsieur
lionel jospin également premier ministre
toujours en période de cohabitation
également candidat l'exécution
présidentielle et enfin j'ai été nommé à
la tête de la sécurité du ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur linh nicolas
sarkozy en 2000
en 2002 je suis resté chef de sa
sécurité de 2002 à 2007
donc alors qu'il a été ministre de
l'intérieur à deux reprises ministre de
finances puis candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il naturellement j'ai été
nommé chef de la sécurité du président
de la république de 2 me en 2007 et ça
s'est interrompue en 2012 à l'issue
j'ai été nommé chef de l'unité de
coordination des grands des grands
événements au cabinet du directeur
général de la police nationale et dans
ce cadre je m'occupais de l'organisation
de grands événements du type 70e
anniversaire du débarquement normandy
kop 21 sommet européen
commémoration diverses et variées voilà
alors à quelques mots sur le groupe de
sécurité du président de la république
comme vous l'avez compris moi j'ai été
nommé chef du groupe de sécurité du
président de la république après déjà
cinq années d'expérience auprès de
nicolas sarkozy
donc c'était je dirais une voix
naturelle puisque apparemment jeu
donnait satisfaction
donc j'ai été maintenu dans mes
fonctions mais cette fois auprès du
président de la république
que dire du groupe de sécurité du
président de la république la
responsabilité du j'espère ce sera plus
facile à dire et bien la sécurité
rapprochée du président de la république
et de sa famille donc comment ça comment
cela s'entend la sécurité du président
de la république c'est une sécurité qui
s'exerce
à tout moment à tout instant qu'on soit
dans des cadres officiels comme dans le
cadre de sa vie privée
quant à sa famille il est il est fait
une analyse de la menace pour savoir
jusqu'à quel niveau des membres de sa
famille cette sécurité doit s'exercer et
bien sûr c'est aussi dans le cadre d'un
échange d'un échange avec le président
de la république lui-même le j'espère à
mon époque était constitué de 90 à 100
personnels selon le moment tous ces
personnels avaient été sélectionnés par
mois ils appartenaient tous au service
de protection des hautes personnalités
ou au raid unité d'intervention de la
police nationale
concernant l'exercice de cette
protection de cette mission de cette
responsabilité je les dis elle s'exerce
à tout instant pour ce qui me concerne
pendant les dix ans pour lesquels j'ai
eu à m'occuper de la sécurité de nicolas
sarkozy et plus particulièrement les
cinq dernières années quand il était
président la république il n'y a eu
aucune exception à ces moments là
jamais le président de la république ne
m'a sollicité pour que la sécurité ne
soit pas présente à ses côtés
quel que soit le moment quelle que soit
la nature de ce moment encore une fois
que ce soit dans un pôle à l'occasion
d'un déplacement officiel comme alain
moment comme à l'occasion d'un moment
privé c'est un lien de confiance qui
doit s'installer avec la personnalité
sans doute pour moi c'était plus aisée
puisque je n'ai pas été nommée à
l'occasion de sa de son élection mais
bien je j'ai eu à accomplir cette
responsabilité depuis cinq ans
auparavant ce qui n'a pas toujours été
le cas
deux de mes prédécesseurs de mesures de
mes successeurs
voilà c'est à peu près ce que je voulais
vous dire maintenant je suis prêt à
répondre à vos questions
merci monsieur le préfet des deux
rapporteurs vous poser quelques
questions il y en a eu une très
importante que je vous posez moi même
quand vous observez les photographies et
les vidéos montrant dans un déplacement
public monsieur alexandre benalla à
proximité du président de la république
avec l' expertise qui est la vôtre
interprétez vous ces images comme le
signe qu'il accomplissait une fonction
de protection rapprochée du président de
la république pourrait tout à fait exact
j'ai vu des images bien sûr de monsieur
vinolas on en a vu deux de large
vous savez le milieu la sécurité
rapprochée c'est un milieu complexe
ils sont rentrés dans les détails on
parle de deux cercles de responsabilité
le siècle le plus proche de la
personnalité dont on a assuré la
protection est prise en compte par le
groupe bleu j'espère pour le président
la république
après on a affaire à des cercles qui
s'éloigne de plus en plus qui sont pris
en compte pas d'autres services de
police et qui constitue un filtre avant
d'arriver jusqu'au président de la
république dans le cercle le plus proche
le métier tels que j'ai eu à l'exercer
par le passé fait qu'on y retrouve bien
sûr d'autres personnes que le président
de la république sinon il serait
totalement isolé des gens à qui souhaite
rencontrer avec qui souhaitent avoir un
échange mais on y rencontre également
des conseillers qui ont par leur rôle à
avoir une proximité avec le président de
la république
et puis on y rencontre également des
gens qui fit quelques longs que l'on
retrouve tels que le préfet
territorialement compétent lorsqu'ils
accueillent le président ou
l'ambassadeur lorsqu'on a dit
l'ambassadeur de france lorsqu'on est à
l'étranger et c'est vrai que la sécurité
rapprochée doit composer avec ces
personnes qui rentrent dans ce cercle
quand je vois l'image
du président macron avec monsieur
benalla proximité il m'est difficile de
dire s'il est présent à ses côtés en
tant que membre de son cabinet ou
membres de sa sécurité pour pouvoir vous
répondre
il faudrait que une action se déroule à
savoir qu'il fallait opérer une
évacuation du président de la république
pour voir à ce moment là qu'ils
agiraient et que ferais tu il
aujourd'hui
la présence à proximité immédiate du
président de la république d'un certain
nombre de passes de personne ne peut pas
déterminer à coup sûr son rôle
je vous ai cité toutes les personnes qui
prouve qu'on pouvait trouver dans
l'environnement immédiat du président la
république qui rentre dans le cercle que
j'ai évoqués on y trouve aussi ce que
j'appelle moi des parasites des gens qui
sont des courtisans et qu'on trouve à
proximité de président de la république
est qu eux constitue une gêne qui nous
appartient de d'évacuer parfois
d'éloigner pour pouvoir exercer cette
fonction
donc aujourd'hui je ne ne peux pas dire
sans qu'il y ait eu une réaction du
groupe de sécurité du président de la
république quel aurait été son rôle
on a des gens qui sont dans ce cercle
pour leur mission de sécurité rapprochée
et d'autres pour leur mission de
conseiller au cabinet d'autres pour deux
des missions de représentation et puis
l'autre des membres de la population qui
sont là pour pouvoir s'adresser au
président de la république donc au
premier regard il est difficile
d'identifier qui fait quoi
encore une fois il aurait fallu que
l'inaction dramatique se déroule pour
pour en connaître pour connaître le rôle
de chacun merci de cette réponse très
circonstancié monsieur jean pierre sueur
juste sur ce point monsieur le préfet
nous avons eu des informations selon
lesquelles il y aurait en fait deux
cents
pour ce qui est de la proximité en radio
du chef de l'état un cercle assez large
qui est celui que vous avez décrit et un
autre le composant le comportant que
quatre personnes
celle qui exerce effectivement la
sécurité rapprochée et qui sont prêts au
titre du gspr
affecté à cette sécurité très ultra
rapprocher est ce que vous vous avez
vécu le fait qu'il y ait ces deux
cercles ou est-ce que ça n'existait pas
quand vous exercez vos fonctions que ça
a été créé depuis ce ménage alors la
sécurité pro che est affaire de moments
d'instants j'ai parlé de moments privés
et de moments public elle est aussi
affaire d' analyse de la menace est donc
le dispositif qui est mis en oeuvre
autour du président de la république
dépendent beaucoup de cette menace est
de 7,2 cet instant ce qui est certain
c'est que quel soit quel que soit le
j'espère donc dont on pourrait parler
c'est que le cercle le plus proche du
président de la république est constitué
de membres du j'espère exclusivement un
pli ya deux siècles
alors après il y à d'autres cercles
autour il ya 1,2 alors le cercle qu'on
utilisait habituellement demande à mon
époque et je crois que c'est encore le
cas aujourd'hui
il était constitué d'un triangle avec un
élément avancé un élément évacuateur est
un élément de contrôle arrière avec un
evra c'est un mâle est en kevlar à sa
disposition pour protéger le président
lorsqu'on était dans une ambiance avec
beaucoup de foule ou avec une menace
avérée ce triangle pouvait se compléter
d'un quart et qu'on appelait carré
tireur toujours mis en oeuvre par le
j'espère
et après on avait à faire des cercles
plus éloignés mais moi quand je parle le
cercle plus éloignées on s'attache à ce
moment-là à d'autres services de police
qui viennent participer à la sécurité du
président la république de plus de
manière plus générale et çà et là ce
moment par les services de police ou de
gendarmerie locaux qui dont le cercle
dont je parle peut aller jusqu'à un
kilomètre autour puisque le contrôle
d'accès à la salle où par exemple le
président s'exprime ou ou la salle
qu'ils visitent
il ce premier contrôle fait partie de la
sécurité du président de la république
elle vient s'ajouter ce dispositif
donc pour moi je le redis le siècle le
plus proche n'est constituée et demandé
à mon époque il n'était constituée
exclusivement de membres du j'espère il
pouvait il pouvait y avoir un deuxième
cercle technique constitué de ce qu'on
appelait un carré tireurs de susciter de
répondre à une agression
toujours constitué de membres du
j'espère et à l'extérieur d'autres
services de police ou de gendarmerie
pouvaient compléter ce dispositif
merci de cette réponse monsieur le
préfet si un collaborateur du président
de la république est constamment à
l'épaule gauche ou à l'épaule droite du
président de la république dans un bain
de foule dans un déplacement dans une
rue
est ce que c'est une gêne pour assurer
sa sécurité selon les moments
cela peut être une gêne tout où l'art à
ce moment là et parfois d'utiliser cette
personne c'est une c'est peut-être des
propos qui ne sont pas tout à fait
correct ce que je vais exprimer mais une
personne qui est un obstacle
vous pouvez en faire un avantage par
rapport à l'agression de vous pouvez à
laquelle vous pouvez avoir à faire il
vous utilisez cette personne comme un
obstacle clairement vous ne pouvez pas
éliminer cette personne puisque le
président peut en avoir besoin
sa place peut tout à fait justifiée à sa
proximité à ce moment-là tout tout l'art
de la sécurité c'est de l'utiliser comme
un matelas
c'est la clé aussi on peut être est
impropre mais un matelas de protection
pour le président en sa faveur
le constat est que on ne peut pas les
éliminer
donc on les utilise la difficulté c'est
quand ils sont trop nombreux
à ce moment là il nous faut faire un tri
puisque il nous faut un minimum d'espacé
pour pouvoir opérer notre mission à la
fois pour intervenir et surtout pour
évacuer en cas d'agression donc cet
espace vital il est nécessaire mais il
n'a pas besoin d'être très important
donc on utilise la plupart du temps ses
membres de cabinets ou c ou ses
représentants de l'état ou ses invités
qui sont à proximité du président un
autre avantage puisque en aucun cas
encore une fois on ne peut placer le
président de la république sous une
bulle et l'isoler totalement du monde
extérieur c'est ce n'est pas son souhait
c'est ce n'est pas notre but monsieur
sûr
puisque les hautes personnalités de
l'elysée nous ont expliqué que monsieur
benalla n'exerçait aucune mission de
police ni de sécurité puisque eux il a
été dit le devant notre commission qu'il
a pu donner des appréciations voir des
instructions à certaines personnes
relevant de des services de sécurité
serait-il crédible qu'il fût eux
instrumentaliser comme obstacle le par
les véritables responsables de la
sécurité
et vous ce que je veux dire suite à
votre déclaration à semer n'a jeu le
terme instrumentalisé ne me convient pas
je vais vous parler de la manière dont
ça fonctionne et à mon époque donner des
instructions chef du j'espère ou un
membre du j'espère à l'époque où j'étais
en charge de cette responsabilité
n'était pas possible
le seul qui était là bas habilité à le
faire c'était moi même bien sûr après je
prenais des informations du chef de
cabinet du président de la république
voire du président de la république
lui-même
je vous rappelle que cette sécurité
s'exprime à tout instant donc quand on
est un moment privé le seul
interlocuteur c'est le président de la
république lui-même pour ce qui concerne
les déplacements officiels
celui qui vous donne les informations
avec lequel se créer un échange c'est le
chef de cabinet qui alla en charge
l'organisation des déplacements du
président de la république donc bien sûr
il y à un échange qui s'installe avec
aller avec le chef de cabinet qui vous
doit le programme du président la
république et pour lequel vous préparez
des dispositifs plus ou moins important
encore une fois selon la nature du
déplacement selon la nature de la menace
qui pèse sur ce moment pour ce qui
concerne monsieur benalla je ne saurais
dire quel rôle le le j'espère du moment
aurait pu lui donner c'est seuls eux
peuvent répondre moi ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que est clairement on avait
réfléchi on s'était entraîné dans cette
ancienne dans ses perspectives à savoir
le président de la république entouré
d'un certain nombre de personnes
pour pouvoir les utiliser au profit de
sa sécurité et non pas se retrouver gêné
par ces gens du fait de leur grande
proximité à l'évidence quand lorsqu'on
est mêlé dans un bain de foule et pour
moi le de toujours deux des vingt ans
d'expérience que j'ai pu avoir dans le
monde de la sécurité rapprochée le le
salon de l'agriculture est un moment
complexe où le bain de foule peut durer
très très longtemps
c'est très pénible et là on a clairement
un moment où il ya le président de la
république souhaite avoir une grande
proximité et on a un certain nombre de
personnes qui vous accompagnent sur
toute la visite vous ne pouvez pas les
éliminer
donc vous les utiliser à votre profit
voilà je sais c'est la précision que je
peux faire mais vous abordé le cas
général du collaborateur par exemple
conseiller technique qui accompagne le
président de la république parce qu'il
est spécialiste de la matière qui fait
l'objet du déplacement tout à fait les
questions nous posons vous le savez bien
sont des questions un tout petit peu
différente parce que il s'agit d'un
collaborateur du président de la
république qui est autorisé à porter une
arme nous a d'ailleurs dit au cours
d'une audition publique qui lui est
arrivé de la porter en présence du
président de la république à l'occasion
de déplacements et qui avait assumé une
mission de sécurité pendant toute la
période de la campagne présidentielle de
2016 2017
et donc ce que nous cherchons à
comprendre c'est le rôle qui pouvait
avoir en matière sécurité aucun des
conseillers qui étaient autour du
président de la république dont vous
avez assuré la sécurité n'avait de
fonctions ambiguë en matière de sécurité
il s'agissait si je comprends bien n'ont
pas de conseiller
portant une arme
et participants d'une manière ou d'une
autre à la sécurité du président de la
république
oui effectivement aucun conseiller
membre du cabinet du président de la
république entre 2007 2012 n'avait en
charge une quelconque mission de
sécurité rapprochée les consignes qu'ils
pouvaient être présents auprès du
président comme vous l'avez dit l'été de
par la nature du déplacement et était là
pour conseiller et aider le président de
la république le chef de cabinet pouvait
être là lui même il les faisait
d'ailleurs quasiment systématiquement
entre lui-même ou son adjoint pour
l'organisation générale le déplacement
et le lien avec les autorités d'accueil
de ce déplacement
c'est bien ça que je veux évoquer vous
savez vous je crois que pourrait tout à
fait clair il faut parler de campagne
électorale pour ma part j'ai eu à
accompagner des personnalités qui ont
toutes les trois fait des campagnes
électorales dans la perspective d'être
élu président de la république
mais à ce moment là j'ai eu à collaborer
avec des services de sécurité deux
parties des services de sécurité privés
mais en aucun cas alors que j'étais
responsable de la sécurité de 2,1 un
premier ministre ou du président la
république ou d'un ministre de
l'intérieur nous n'avons cédé cette
prérogative qui était la nôtre au profit
des services de sécurité mis en oeuvre
par les parties qui dépendent et dont
dépend des ces personnalités il qu'il y
avait eu un partage qui étaient
clairement définis à savoir que la
sécurité mis en oeuvre par ces partis
avaient en charge la sécurité éloigné du
déplacement du candidat tant que
l'organisation de la salle du meeting la
sécurité du public la sécurité de la
scène mais la sécurité rapprochée du
candidat parce qu'il était premier
ministre ou parce qu'ils étaient membres
du gouvernement étaient toujours de la
responsabilité de la sécurité rapprochée
étatique ça ça ne faisait aucun doute
donc ça faisait l'objet de négociations
des changes puisque bien sûr pour ce
dispositif fonctionne il faut préparer
il s'agit pas de se marcher sur les
pieds il faut que les responsabilités
soient clairement établies
donc moi j'ai eu la chance de de
préparer d'organiser la sécurité
rapprochée de ses trois candidats
il est vrai que si on regarde ce qui
s'était passé pour les deux derniers
présidents de la république
les deux derniers présidents de la
république ont été élus alors qu'il
n'était pas accompagné d'une sécurité
étatiques que ce soit monsieur hollande
il a été élu alors qu'il n'était pas
membre du gouvernement et monsieur macro
non plus donc
et ces deux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle ont eu une sécurité qui
leur a été délégué par les partis dont
il était issu et et uniquement lui si la
sécurité du candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
elle est très clairement décrites et
elle ne s'engage qu'à partir d'une
certaine dote d'une certaine date en
accord avec le camp dial candidat
lui-même et qui en fait ne correspond
qu'au quelques dernières semaines avant
le premier tour mais toute la campagne
électorale qui peut parfois être très
longue est à ce moment là prise en
charge par dessiner les sociétés de
sécurité privées ou par des militants il
et quels militants la plupart du temps
ne sont pas armés pour accompagner ces
candidats et ce n'est pas mon expérience
encore une fois moi j'ai eu à m'occuper
de trois candidats à l'élection
présidentielle mais ils avaient tous des
responsabilités gouvernementales à ce
moment là le candidat nicolas sarkozy en
2007 n'était plus ministre
à partir du mois de
février deux mois de mars là ça n'a duré
que quelques mois et à ce moment là il a
eu une protection de l'état immédiate
puisque c'était tardivement qu'il a
quitté le gouvernement il y là il a
continué à avoir une protection en
nombre moins important en tant qu'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur puisque je le
rappelle tous les anciens chefs de
l'état tous les anciens premiers
ministres et des anciens ministres de
l'intérieur ont droit à cette protection
fournie par l'état dans un nombre faible
et mais la concomitance de sa
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
et encore une fois son nez sa démission
est venu tardivement quelques mois avant
le premier tour a permis une continuité
de cette sécurité
même si le nombre d'agents qui étaient
désignés pour cette sécurité était
moindre
bien sûr comme quand il était ministre
de l'intérieur je vous remercie madame
jourdain
merci monsieur le président monsieur
préfet une question pour continuer sur
ce poids il nous est expliqué en
audition publique qu'en réalité il avait
été décidé que systématiquement ce
serait un membre de la chefferie de
cabinet qui se trouverait à proximité du
président de la république
s'agit-il véritablement d'un changement
ce systématisme et vous paraît-il de
nature à assurer la protection du
président de la république de république
en toute situation
ce n'était pas le cas à l'époque où j'ai
exercé la présence du chef de cabinet ou
de son adjoint à proximité du président
de la république n'était pas
systématique
elles étaient systématiques sur les
déplacements du président de la
république mais pas systématique dont
son environnement le plus proche
il accompagnait le président la
république pour faire face à tout
événement du type organisationnel en
lien avec le préfet territorialement
compétent encore une fois ou avec
l'ambassadeur de france ou avec les
autorités étrangères qui nous
accueillait mais sa présence n'était pas
toujours immédiatement à côté du
président la république
ça clairement c'est un choix du
président de la république lui-même
c'est lui qui définit qu'il souhaite
avoir à ses côtés c'est c'est une
quelque chose qui est propre à chaque
président il ne faut pas oublier que la
sécurité du président république c'est
avant tout un lien de confiance qui doit
s'installer et que les règles sans être
transgressée s'adapte à la personnalité
du président mais encore une fois je
tiens beaucoup à ce lien de confiance
parce que la sécurité rapprochée c'est
quelque chose d'impalpable c'est c'est
fait ou ce n'est pas fait c'est bien
assuré c'est bien prévu où ça ne l'est
pas c'est souvent difficile à percevoir
et je crois que la plus grande réussite
pour un chef de la sécurité du président
de la république c'est que le président
de la république ne pense pas sa
sécurité et que pour lui elle soit une
évidence
rien qu'en vous regardent-ils c'est que
c'est tout et tout est prêt et que lille
ne doit se préoccuper que de ce qui est
ce on promet son rôle premier
à aucun moment il ne doit vous posez la
question sinon je pense qu' il y ait
chèque et que le titre le lien de
confiance n'existe pas donc la présence
du chef de cabinet ou de son adjoint à
proximité de nicolas sarkozy président
de la république n'était pas
systématique parce qu'il ne le
souhaitait pas encore une fois si
d'autres dispositifs peuvent être mis en
oeuvre
je reviens ce que je vous ai dit le
dispositif ce qui a été sa d'ap à ces
personnes qui sont immédiatement à
proximité du président même s'il doit
être restés limités pour que cette
fonction puisse exercer en étant dans un
petit peu la question de madame jourda
les premiers ministres dont vous avez
assurer la sécurité
je crois que l'organisation d'un
déplacement le premier ministre
ressemble un peu à celle d'un
déplacement du président de la
république surtout en période de
cohabitation
surtout en période de cohabitation ce
qui était le cas nous et dans les deux
cas
et avez vous le souvenir que dans ses
déplacements
l'organisation de la sécurité ait eu la
tenir compte de la présence du chef de
cabinet ou du chef adjoint de cabinet à
l'épaule du premier ministre pendant ses
déplacements à l'épaule systématiquement
non à proximité du président du premier
ministre oui quand je dis à proximité
quelques mètres et qui est différent du
site qui est différent et pour pouvoir
échanger avec lui jamais très éloignés
très bien même journal oui je vais
changer de sujet si vous voulez bien
monsieur le président monsieur le préfet
vous nous avez déjà indiqué tout à
l'heure quelles étaient les conditions
et modalités de recrutement des membres
du j'espère je vais peut-être un peu
précises et les questions si vous voulez
bien nous répondre sur ce point du fait
de votre expérience
il s'agit évidemment de préciser quelles
sont les modalités de recrutement des
membres du j'espère etiez-vous
totalement autonome dans la sélection
des candidats s'agissait-il
exclusivement de personnes appartenant
forces de sécurité intérieure dans
quelle mesure le service de la
protection intervient-il dans cette
procédure de recrutement et il
systématiquement informés des
recrutements au sein du j'espère pendant
que j'ai exercé cette fonction
la totalité des membres du gspm ont été
recrutés par moi même les limites à ce
recrutement était qu'il doit elle devait
appartenir au service de protection des
hautes personnalités
aujourd'hui devenu service de la
protection ou au raid unité
d'intervention de la police nationale
il n'y avait pas d'exception quoi vous
rajoutez les fonctionnaires de les
fonctionnaires de police qui
appartiennent au service de protection
des qui appartenait aux services de
production de protection des hautes
personnalités ont tous toutes subi des
tests physiques psychologiques diverses
et variées pour pouvoir à peut
appartenir à ce service il en est de
même bien sûr pour lui disais
d'intervention qui est le vrai
voilà ces conditions là sont nécessaires
et suffisantes
aujourd'hui il n'y avait aucune émission
du service de ce qui est aujourd'hui le
service de la protection aucune
immixtion dans le choix vous recrutiez
au sein de ce service mais il n'y avait
ni droit de veto une immixtion dans le
choix de ddr candidats il y avait un
échange avec le directeur du service de
la protection des hautes personnalités
mais à partir du moment où un policier
est membre du service de protection des
hautes personnalités c'est qu'elle a
satisfait les tests donc il n'y a aucune
raison de se poser à son corps devant ce
recrutement au sein du j'espère sauf à
ce qu'il ait commis une faute
depuis son arrivée au sein du sphp ce
qui normalement aurait dû conduire à son
éviction
donc il n'y avait aucune difficulté à
pouvoir choisir au sein du vivier du
service de protection des hautes
personnalités les membres du j'espère
c'était très naturel
il a il en est de même au sein du raid
des services également par lequel on
accueille pour lequel on accède à
travers des sélections donc ce sont des
services pour lesquels il faut avoir
soumis satisfait à des tests
essentiellement physique mais pas que
pour pouvoir rejoindre ses services donc
c'est une condition suffisante pour
appartenir géo j'espère est en tout cas
c'est c'est elle que moi je les exercer
je remercie madame jourdain
dernière question les personnes qui se
trouvent à proximité immédiate du
président de la république mais qui ne
font pas partie du j'espère sont l
informer de leur rôle de matelas non ils
ne le sont pas en tant que telles elles
ne le sont pas en tant que tel mais je
pense que celles qui en ont qui en ont
l'habitude ont compris quel rôle on
pouvait leur faire jouer quand on est
membre d'un cabinet du président la
république et qu'on accompagne
fréquemment le président la république
on voit bien quelle attitude peut avoir
un officier de sécurité au plus près du
président la république quand on peut
percevoir que par moments on vous
utilisent comme obstacle
pas toujours mais je vous remercie
monsieur sur une question monsieur le
préfet premièrement vous savez que nous
sommes dotés de nombreuses auditions
maintenant de leurs comptes rendus et
donc d'un nombre conséquent de
contradictions il nous a été dit donc
monsieur benalla n'exercer aucune
mission de sécurité ni de protection
il nous a été dit aussi qu'il exerçait
la coordination des services de sécurité
de la présidence la république
il ne nous a été aussi dit qu'ils
étaient soit un des membres d'une
mission qui avait pour objet de repenser
les liens qui pouvaient exister ou la
coordination qui devrait exister entre
le commandement militaire et le gspr il
nous a aussi été suggéré qu'il était en
fait non seulement membre de cette de ce
groupe de travail mais qu'il y joue un
rôle plus déterminant pour concevoir une
conception future de la sécurité du chef
de l'état est ce que dans vos fonctions
cette question du la coordination entre
le gspr et le commandement militaire
s'est posée est ce qu'il ya eu des
groupes de travail de ce type
quel rôle jouez les représentants du
cabinet du président et je complète la
question est ce que il la zone de
chevauchement éventuel entre le
commandement militaire du palais et le
groupe de sécurité de la présidence de
la présidence de la république est
tellement important que des
dysfonctionnements seraient apparus
lié aux difficultés de coordination de
ces deux entités l'une chargée la
sécurité du palais l'autre chargés de la
sécurité du président de la république
quand il a quitté le palais monsieur le
préfet alors il est vrai que j'aurais dû
signaler que si le j'espère est
responsable de la sécurité du président
la république à tout instant ce n'est
pas vrai au sein du palais présidentiel
c'est la garde républicaine qui a en
charge cette responsabilité c'est la
seule exception
j'aurais dû le dire je m'en excuse et je
m'en excuse vis-à-vis du du commandement
militaire d'ailleurs à l'époque
moi j'avais des réactions des relations
précise très régulières parfois
quotidienne avec le le commandement
militaire avec le commandant militaire
lui-même pour bien sûr coordonner les
entrées et les sorties du président de
la république mais clairement je n'avais
je ne m'immisce est pas dans le travail
de du des gardes républicains à
l'intérieur du palais l'elysée et ceux
ci n'avaient pas à connaître de mon
travail à l'extérieur du palais de
l'elysée jeu 7 7
c'est ce partage des responsabilités
était clairement établie depuis toujours
c'est un partage qui s'imposait à nous
je n'ai pas émis le besoin de le
remettre en question je n'ai jamais eu à
participer à une étude quelconque sur un
renouvellement du fonctionnement de de
la sécurité du président de la
république
si je veux pousser un peu plus loin mon
raisonnement
j'ai beaucoup parlé de sécurité mais il
faut aussi parler d'organisation le
j'espère en responsabilité de la
sécurité rapprochée mais aussi
l'organisation générale des déplacements
du président de la république
cela sous-entend la mise en oeuvre de
fonction j'espère de ne pas être trop
théorique mais à mon époque on était en
responsabilité de ce qu'on appelle les
cortèges donc la gestion des véhicules
du cortège présidentiel
on était en responsabilité de la gestion
de l'hébergement de la délégation du
président la république ce qui peut
représenter un grand nombre de personnes
à la loge et de la gestion des bagages
de la délégation présidentielle et en
particulier lorsqu'elle est elle se rend
à l'étranger de la gestion de delà de la
discipline de la presse qui se trouve à
proximité du président la république
ce qui fait que quand concrètement
lorsqu'on a un dispositif de sécurité
on a en fait un nombre important
d'agents engagé mais on peut dire que le
nombre le plus le moins nombreux si
celui qui est dédié uniquement à la
sécurité rapprochée
on va dire de 2,3 à 10 selon les moments
mais ça peut être plus important si on
est dans des moments particulièrement
complexe et difficile mais qu'on peut
rapidement avoir une vingtaine d'agents
du j'espère engagés sur des missions
d'organisation générale
alors tout le monde n'entend pas cette
organisation de la même façon je crois
que vous aurez entendre d'autres
responsables
d'anciens responsables du gspm à
l'époque où j'ai dirigé le j'espère moi
j'ai souhaité prendre sous ma
responsabilité
toutes ces fonctions de manière à
pouvoir avoir une vision complète de la
sécurité du président la république pour
vous l'immerger ou au mieux à partir du
moment où le président aurait pu lui
descendait d'un avion pour se rendre
quelque part
j'estimais être responsable de tout ce
qui se passait autour de lui donc ça
veut dire de la voiture dans laquelle
ils montent mais aussi du cortège de
voitures qui l'accompagnent des lieux
dans lesquels il se rend dès de la
nourriture qu'ils mangent de de l'hôtel
dans laquelle il dort ou de la résidence
dans lequel il dort mais ça s'étendait à
sa délégation puisque bien sûr un chef
de l'état ne peut pas être isolé c'est
une vision trop étroite de penser qu' on
ne s'occupe que du président de la
république la discipline la presse j'en
ai parlé aussi on sait très bien que on
revient dans ces personnes qui évoluent
autour du président de la république
il nous faut les canaliser pour que pour
qu'on puisse travailler nous sécurité
pour que le président de la république
puisse se déplacer puisse avancer dans
les lieux où il doit se rendre
donc ces aspects là qui peuvent amener à
laisser penser qu'on pourrait
à voir à repenser le fonctionnement du
j'espère moi je n'en ai pas eu le besoin
puisque j'ai exercé ses fonctions
conformément avec l'assentiment du
président de la république et du chef de
cabinet j'ai mes fonctions sont allés
jusque là et il faut bien signalé que à
paris et parfois en province sur des
moments très officiel les conducteurs
sont fournies par les gardes
républicains
mais qu'ont dit les conducteurs de
sécurité qu'on retrouve les gardes
républicains sur un certain nombre de
cérémonies officielles pour des dépôts
de gerbes en particulier que quelques
donc il peut y avoir selon la
personnalité du chef du j'espère le
besoin peut-être de réformer celui ci
personnellement j'en ai jamais vu la
nécessité jeu je suis pas persuadé
qu'une réforme soit nécessaire moi je
crois qu'aujourd'hui la sécurité du
président de la république est bien
assurée malgré l'époque complexe que le
envie je j'ai pas de doute là dessus je
vous remercie
une situation est très précises lorsque
vous étiez en poste à l'élysée avez vous
eu connaissance que d'autres personnes
que les membres du commandement
militaire éléments du gspr que disposer
da et disposer d'un port d'armes
ménard non bien sûr jamais eu
connaissance de ce type de faits toutes
les années où vous avez dans vos
fonctions vous avez eu connaissance
d'aucun organe pour aucune personne
quelle qu'elle soit
appartenant au personnel de l'est
mon cabinet en dehors bien sûr de du
j'espère et du commandement militaire
mais non non non et encore une fois ci
il menace avait pesé sur un conseiller
plutôt que de lui attribuer une arme on
lui a attribué une sécurité je vous
remercie
même question pour matignon
même question pour matignon même réponse
est bien et vous qui avez connu deux
cohabitations pensez vous que le
rattachement du gspr au ministère de
l'intérieur pose le moindre problème
pour le président de la république
non non je ne le crois pas pour moi
c'est il ya deux forces de sécurité
intérieure en france qui sont toutes les
deux légitimes à exercer cette
responsabilité
si je veux être bien complet il est vrai
que le j'espère que je dirigeais à
l'époque n'était composée que de
policiers mais c'était la possibilité
qui est lancé le texte elle détecte et
bien de policiers ou de gendarmes de
militaires de la gendarmerie nationale
aujourd'hui c'est une équipe pied qui
mixte je ne sais pas si un équilibre
entre entre ses personnels c'est pas mon
sujet d'intérêt aujourd'hui
je crois que c'est encore une fois tout
en restant dans les textes la sécurité
rapprochée du président doit être
adaptée à la volonté du président la
république
est-ce que ce qui se passe au sein du
gspr et hermétique par rapport au
ministre d'intérieur autrement dit ils
informés par les membres du j'espère ou
pas le commandant du gspm des faits et
gestes du président de la république
alors pour tout à fait honnête si j'ai
re place ça dans la situation qui était
la mienne en de rares occasions et je
vais vous indiquer lesquelles j'ai eu à
signaler des faits au ministre de
l'intérieur ou au directeur général de
la police nationale il me revient tout
de suite 2 mais il y en a peut-être
quelques autres mais ça reste
l'exception l'exception a pu se produire
lorsque le président de la république a
vu un malaise lors de son footing dans
le parc du château de versailles un mois
de juillet donc bien sûr là j'avais
rendu compte immédiatement de ce fait au
directeur général de la police nationale
et au ministre de l'intérieur
et puis aussi lors du déplacement en
libye après la chute de kadhafi
j'avais eu des contacts avec le
directeur général de la police nationale
sur le dispositif lui-même de sécurité
que j'avais à mettre en oeuvre sur le
territoire de la libye puisque tout
simplement il me fallait faire appel à
des forces supérieures à celles du
j'espère un du raid en particulier mais
aussi à des crs vu la nature du
déplacement et en l'absence là d'un
dernier tie dye pouvons nous accueillir
et nous assister dans la sécurité du
président de la république mais en tout
état de cause il est certain que je n'ai
jamais rendu compte de l'emploi du temps
du président de la république à
quiconque je n'ai jamais rendu compte du
dispositif que j'ai mis en oeuvre à
quiconque
si ce n'est au président lui-même très
bien je vous remercie
alors nous avons un certain nombre de
collègues qui souhaitent poser des
questions mes chers collègues
la concision reste de mise et si vous
pouviez ne pas dépasser la
traditionnelle minute
je vous en serais reconnaissant et
surtout les collègues qui veulent aussi
poser des questions vous en seront
reconnaissants
monsieur grosdidier qui comme d'habitude
va donner le bon exemple prend la parole
en premier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
préfet le nous expliquer d'abord que
monsieur benalla ne ne portait jamais
son arme dans les déplacements publics
mais les pouvez les porter dans son
déplacement privé d'ailleurs le
directeur du cabinet du président de
république qui est à l'origine de la
demande de port d'armes
vous expliquez que cela pouvait
contribuer à renforcer la sécurité du
président notamment dans les
déplacements privés ou la protection
était plus complexe parce que plus
allégée que dans les déplacements
publics alors on comprend mal vous nous
expliquez bien qu' il n'y a jamais
rupture dans la surveillance par le
j'espère du président de république 24
heures sur 24 365 jours par an alors
dans ce cas et ça nous est il a été
confirmé que cela continue à fonctionner
comme ça aujourd'hui
sous ce quinquennat est ce que un
élément de l'entourage du président de
la république armée et donc de redon la
demande de port d'armes a été d'ailleurs
motivé par son rôle de sécurité à
l'elysée est-il un élément de protection
supplémentaire comme peut l'être un
matelas mais qui n'a pas besoin d'être
armé ou et peut-il au contraire est un
élément de perturbation par un usage de
larmes qui n'est pas forcément
strictement coordonnées à l'instant t
avec les forces du j'espère quoi d'autre
auriez-vous demandeurs vous d'avoir un
autre élément armé en plus du gspr où
était ce pour vos plutôt un élément
perturbations pour assurer la sécurité
du président je vous remercie de cette
question monsieur le préfet je n'étais
pas demandeur de ce type de dead or
j'espère le j'espère dimensionne son
dispositif selon le besoin selon
l'analyse de la menace qu'il réalise et
s'il a besoin d'être assistés ils
sollicitent d'autres services de forces
de sécurité intérieure pour savoir si
c'est une gêne une gêne ou une aide
la question qu'il faut poser c'est
participer t-il aux entraînements s'il
participe aux entraînements ce n'est pas
une jeune j'aimais encore une fois la
sécurité rapprochée affaires de réflexe
qu'on acquiert puisqu'il faut une
réaction instantanée
donc cela se travaille entraînement avec
des mises en situation dans le siècle le
plus rapproché
chacun doit connaître son rôle et ça se
travaille à l'entraînement je vous
remercie madame esther benbassa aussi
monsieur le président monsieur le préfet
je vais vous poser une question qui peut
peut-être pas l'être un peu théorique
peut-être vous saurez répondre
comment peut-on mais peut-on expliquer
les missions d'une personne comme
monsieur benalla dans la production dans
la protection du président parallèlement
aux j'espère et aussi quel est le seuil
de tolérance du j'espère lorsqu'il y a
une personnalité comme monsieur benalla
jusqu'où peut aller cette tolérance
monsieur ménard je suis très gêné pour
répondre à cette question de vous pouvez
la reformuler oui et c'est monsieur ban
a été d'en bas on était dans la
protection du président il ya le
j'espère
vous nous avez parlé du triangle vous
nous avez parlé de de dison de de la
gestion des différentes personnalités
des personnes qui sont autour du
président comment se fait-il que le
j'espère laisser faire une personne qui
était quand même dans la protection
quasiment 10 rêve enfin pour la
protection directe du président c'est
quand même miss alès assez mystérieux
parce que le geste belle a l'air d'être
très organisé très strictes et là on
voit ce personnage qui se promet alors
on sait pas s'il a une âme ou pas etc
alors monsieur le préfet je croyais
avoir répondu à cette question il y à
des personnalités auprès du président
qui sont incontournables
nous ne sommes pas là pour empêcher la
proximité du président la république
avec ses conseillers avec les autorités
qui l'accueille ou avec le public on
doit le prendre en compte si dans le
paysage du président la république il y
a une personnalité incontournable
nous devons faire avec encore une fois
j'aime bien faire une comparaison entre
la sécurité à la française et la
sécurité à l'américaine le sécrétaire le
sucre et de services interdit sécurité à
la française s'adapte c'est toute la
différence
donc s'il ya une personnalité qui est
souhaitée à proximité du président de la
république à tout instant où quasiment à
tout instant nous faisons avec nous nous
adaptons la difficulté c'est quand elles
sont trop nombreuses
mais une personnalité à proximité de lui
cela peut être le préfet qui l'accueille
sur le territoire où il sort en ça peut
être le conseiller en charge du thème
pour lequel le déplacement à court ça
peut être un interprète
ça peut être un chef d'entreprise qui
l'accueille pour visiter sa société
ces gens là existe on ne peut pas
empêcher ces gens-là d'être à proximité
de président le fait que ce soit
récurrent n'a pas d'effet nous faisons
avec
je vous remercie madame brigitte
lherbier c'est le préfet justement vous
vous prononcez le mot adaptation il
s'adapte est ce que le gspr s'adapte sur
le fait ou est ce qu on a mûri il a
suffisamment de renseignements pour
s'adapter
avez-vous des réunions d'état-major à
l'avance pour dire telle personne sera
là savez-vous lors de ces réunions qui
portera une arme ou pas parce que
monsieur ben daley nous a dit que
quelques fois il avait les larmes parce
qu'il venait directement de chez lui
donc personne ne pouvait ou pas être au
courant damman est ce que ça vous semble
normal je pense qu' il peut y avoir
quand même une organisé sur une âme du
préfet alors bien sûr tous les
déplacements du président de la
république se prépare même s'ils sont
privés parfois la préparation commence
avec des réunions en préfecture
n'oublions pas qu'en france le préfet
reste responsable de la sécurité du
président de la république sur son
territoire le j'espère se pose à ce
moment là en tant que conseiller du
préfet or la plus la plupart du temps
les préfets suivre les conseils du
j'espère puisque nous sommes les
praticiens mais malgré tout c'est lui
qui en assume la responsabilité
bien sûr nous les tenons un certain
nombre d'informations et nous sont
fournies par la chefferie de cabinet
quant au programme mais également quant
à la délégation qui accompagne le
président la république nous fait nous
faisons état d'une analyse de la menace
cette menace elle est régulièrement
remise à jour de manière globale et elle
fait l'objet d'une analyse précise à
chaque déplacement officiel bien sûr ça
peut être le cas aussi pour un
déplacement privé en particulier s'il a
lieu à l'étranger
donc tous ces critères nous permet de
dimensionner un dispositif encore une
fois si le président de la république
sort du palais pour aller acheter un
médicament à la pharmacie du coin qui
peut lui arriver
le dispositif sera très léger très
discret il n'aura il en sera tout autre
lors du défilé du 14 juillet
dans le même sur le même site quasiment
c'est tout est affaire d'adaptation j'y
reviens et cette adaptation elle est
liée à aux informations qu'on détient la
na li à l'analyse que l'on que l'on peut
faire et elle s'adapte aux besoins du
président la république parce qu'encore
une fois il ne s'agit pas de le placer
sous une bulle
il s'agit de lui permettre d'exercer ses
responsabilités et d'aller au contact de
la population ce qui reste notre
objectif
je vous remercie madame lherbier vous
des relances et non pas relancer mais
tout simplement vous avez comme
information je voudrais savoir ça si
vous aviez vous avez comme information
le nom de tous ceux qui détiennent une
arme autour du président a plus ou moins
distant que ça soit périmètre rapproché
ou plus ou moins éloignées on est quand
même dans une période de terroristes
aient compris monsieur bénard que
personne d'autre que les membres du g
spern avait une arme dans les
déplacements du président de la
république personne d'autre que les
membres des forces de sécurité à des
fonctions de sécurité oui parce qu'il
n'ya pas que le cercle et troisième avec
les forces de police ou de gendarmerie
locale le sont aussi
les officiers de sécurité étrangers
lorsque le président accompagné une
autorité étrangère le sont aussi et tout
cela est clairement établie donc le nom
non mais les personnes elles-mêmes
oui et encore une fois à mon époque on
avait mis en place un dispositif
d'identification des conseillers qui
étaient sous la forme d'un pin's je
crois qu'il existe toujours un pin's
présidence de république ce qui
permettait aux agents de sécurité d'être
sûr qu'on avait affaire à un conseiller
de la présence de rythmiques même si
rapidement les connaît tous
mais c'est aussi une aide pour les
autorités locales qui en moins
l'habitude identifier ces personnes et
puis lors des déplacements officiels ont
mis en oeuvre il ça c'est plutôt le
protocole qui le fait d des badges pour
identifier les membres de la délégation
qu'ils soient journalistes conseiller
interprètes invités
ça permet d'identifier qui est autour de
vous et quand on est à l'étranger
le pays qui vous accueille et organise
les choses de la même façon
bon dans les moments privés bien sûr
cette identification est moins certaine
mais aussi l'inde
un nombre beaucoup moins important de
personnes qui gravitent autour du
président de la république dans ces
instants-là merci monsieur henri leroy
mais monsieur le préfet bonjour vous
avez manifestement une expérience la
sécurité rapprochée vous avez été
commandant de police jean a été sous
préfet préfet vous avez exercé pendant
dix ans dans la sécurité pas reprocher
on peut dire que vous êtes une sorte
d'expert ma question est très simple
justement en tant qu'expert ne pensez
vous pas que quelqu'un qui se
trouveraient dans la sécurité rapprochée
du président comme c'était le cas de
monsieur b dallas et comme les syndicats
de police que nous avons entendu on dit
qu'il est terrorisée ne pensez-vous pas
que c'était devenu une gêne dans le
cadre du périmètre de sécurité pour le
gspr qui sont composées d'experts qu'ils
aient qui qu'ils soient issus de la
police comme de la gendarmerie ils ont
une maîtrise des armes ils ont une
maîtrise de la sécurité par rapprocher
d'eux mêmes leur sang froid
donc ne pensez-vous pas véritablement
que c'était une gêne plutôt qu'un atout
parce que matelas peut aussi gêné les
forces de sécurité en réalité ça me gêne
plus que ça ne les arrange
et ne pensez vous pas si vous aviez été
dans ce cas que le patron du gspr a dû
en faire part au président de la
république par l'intermédiaire du chef
du cabinet ou du directeur de cabinet
sur une présence parfois permanente de
monsieur ben alla au côté du président
que ce soit officiel dans les
déplacements officiels ou privés
voila j'aimerais bien avoir votre avis
en tant qu'expert oui alors monsieur le
préfet on vous demande de vous situer
dans le cadre d' hypothèse que vous
n'avez pas vécu mais comme observateur
comprendre que ça n'est pas forcément
très très facile pour vous aimez nous
demandons à bien comprendre ce qui a pu
se produire
et donc je comprends la question de
monsieur leroi allez-y c'est mon arrêt
je ne peux pas imaginer ce qu'ont pu
être les conversations ce que peuvent
être les conversations de l'actuel chef
du j'espère avec le président de la
république
ce que je peux corriger dans ce que vous
avez dit d'abord c'est que je suis dans
le nom de la sécurité rapprochée depuis
20 ans et pas dix ans et puisque excusez
moi pour la précision et concernant le
matelas je veux pas qu'on s'attache 3,7
ce mot je savais qu'il pouvait générer
quelques remarques quelques réactions
mais ça n'est pas un atout on s'adapte
encore une fois nous préférons avoir les
mains libres
les coudées franches mais nous nous
adaptons c'est notre rôle
encore une fois je reviens à toute la
différence entre certains services de
protection et le service à la française
notre maître mot ça reste l'adaptation
donc on fait avec bien sûr préféré qu'il
n'y ait pas d'obstacle entre le
président la république et non mais s'il
n'est qu'une vision de l'esprit le
président la république seul sous un job
ça n'existe pas merci messieurs profil
madame jourdain une question je suis
président merci monsieur le préfet lors
des déplacements privés
yat-il systématiquement ou inutile
puisque dans votre expérience
systématiquement un membre de la
chefferie de cabinet auprès du président
oui systématiquement soit le chef de
cabinet ce soit son adjoint sur les
déplacements officiels il y avait privé
vous aviez alors sur les déplacements
officiels systématiquement sur les
déplacements privés très
exceptionnellement
je vous remercie madame marie pierre de
la gontrie
merci président monsieur le préfet ma
question est simple quelques
connaissances
avez-vous aujourd'hui des fonctions
réelles qu'occupait monsieur benalla ce
préfet alors je vais parler de mes
fonctions après le j'espère après le
j'espère je les dis dans ma présentation
j'étais chef de l'unité de coordination
des grands événements au cabinet du
directeur général de la police nationale
et j'ai rencontré monsieur benalla à
l'occasion de l'organisation du sommet
de décembre 2017
ce mec s'est déroulée sur l'île seguin
sommet pour le financement des actions
de la cote clim pour pour faire un
raccourci ce sommet he a rassemblé une
quarantaine de chefs d'état du étrangers
et donc en ma qualité de d'experts dans
l'organisation pour la sécurité des
grands événements g j'ai eu à rencontrer
monsieur bnl à cette occasion il était
le représentant de la présidence de la
république pour l'organisation de ce
sommet il a dirigé plusieurs réunions la
auquel j'ai assisté en tant qu'adjoint
au chef du chef de cabinet ou chargés de
mission je ne sais pas exactement mais
plutôt comme adjoint du chef de cabinet
et nuit fait des missions de
reconnaissance sur l'île seguin sur le
bateau mouche qu'ont utilisés les chefs
d'état pour se rendre sur cette île à
ses côtés et son positionnement était
clairement celui du chef de cabinet du
président le chef de cabinet adjoint du
président la république mais c'était
peut-être pas votre question
retenez reformuler la pardon
depuis le début de notre commission
denquête de nos travaux nous avons
auditionné 24 ou 25 personnes et nous
n'arrivons toujours pas à approcher de
manière extrêmement précise
les fonctions qu'occupait monsieur
benalla en matière de sécurité
vous n'êtes plus dans cette fonction là
pour autant évidemment les relations
professionnelles que vous avez le milieu
professionnel dans lequel vous exercez
aujourd'hui vous amène nécessairement
avoir connaissance de des fonctions de
monsieur benalla si elle touche aux
questions de sécurité donc j'entends par
votre réponse que vous ne souhaitez pas
répondre c'est à dire vous faites
référence je n'ai pas en cause
l'expérience que vous avez eue avec lui
parce qu'il était sans doute
effectivement chef adjoint de cabinet
pour un certain nombre de manifestations
et d'organisation mais nous essayons
d'identifier ses fonctions dans le
domaine de la sécurité avec le port
d'armes avec et et erratique et donc
c'est sur ce point là que je souhaitais
savoir quelle était la connaissance que
vous pouviez avoir de ce rôle là ce
veinard vous savez j'étais engagé
pendant 20 ans dans le monde de la
sécurité rapprochée ça ça a eu un fort
impact sur ma vie privée et j'ai
souhaité tourner la page à la fin de ma
mission auprès de nicolas sarkozy dans
la manière dont je l'exercé à savoir
reprendre une vie un peu plus normale et
je me suis fait aussi un principe de non
ingérence de nos commentaires de dvd de
la fonction de la mission de sécurité
auprès du président la république telle
qu'elle a pu être exercées sous monsieur
hollande comme sous celle de monsieur
macron savez c'est un métier éminemment
difficile le lien de confiance est
essentielle et tient ça encore une fois
se met ce métier tellement difficile que
je ne porterai jamais de jugement sur la
manière dont s'exerce cette fonction
aujourd'hui où après mois ou même avant
moi je sais que on n'a pas toujours les
coudées franches
je sais que on n'a pas toujours toute la
latitude mais après c'est une affaire de
deux personnes une affaire de relation
que le président la république et on
fait au mieux donc à aucun moment jamais
je ne porterai un jugement sur la
manière dont sont exercé ses fonctions
aujourd'hui où depuis que je les exercer
moi même je sais que vous rencontrerez
un autre chef de la sécurité du
président de la république avec un
ancien chef de la sécurité du président
de la république investi moi j'ai eu à
travailler sous lionel jospin premier
ministre
nous partageons des points de vue pas
tous et nous avons exercé une omission
de manière différente parce que nous
avions à faire des personnalités
différentes
il ya un cadre mais qui est suffisamment
large pour qu'ils puissent s'adapter à
la personnalité du président la
république je vous remercie madame de
l'autre merci président merci monsieur
préfet pour la clarté de vos propos et
et le détail de précision dans dans vos
réponses
moi j'ai deux questions vous parlez d'un
triangle d'un carré selon la pression et
le monde autour du président comment est
il recruter est ce qu'il est imposé au
président ou est-ce qu effectivement il
ya un recrutement à profil par rapport à
la personnalité du président ça se passe
comment et si effectivement cette
confiance ne s'établit pas est ce que
vous avez eu des demandes de la part du
président ou de personnalités de
changement ou même d'intégration d'un
homme de confiance qui puisse rassurer
le président est-ce que vous avez eue à
vivre cela auquel cas ce qu'on peut
s'opposer à une demande du président qui
est ce qu'un préfet de police où peut se
poser à ce type de demande ça c'était ma
première question
la deuxième c'est que vous parlez
effectivement des déplacements officiels
et des déplacements privés vous parlez
du président de la république et de sa
famille jusqu'à quel degré dans sa
famille
vallat protection là je parle de
brigitte macro une voix alexandre
benalla sur des photos autour de
brigitte macron est-ce que effectivement
c'est le gspr comme on nous l'a dit ou
alors ça a été qui couvrent
effectivement ses déplacements même
privé ou est ce que vous faites appel à
un autre cercle qui n'est pas le
deuxième sac celui de la police
nationale parce que vous manqué
d'effectif et donc vous avez besoin de
faire appel à des personnalités
extérieures
merci monsieur le préfet alors pour le
recrutement
à mon époque je ne me suis jamais fait
imposer un quelconque recrutement par
qui que ce soit que ce soit le président
de la république le ministre de
l'intérieur le préfet de police
le directeur général de la police
nationale c'est toujours moi qui ai
décidé de qui appartenait au j'espère
dans les limites que je vous ai expliqué
à savoir il fallait appartenir au sphp
ou au raid donc avoir satisfait aux
sélections sportives pour pouvoir à part
appartenir à ce cercle à aucun moment le
président de la république ne s'est
jamais étonné de qui pouvait être à ses
côtés n'a jamais fait de remarques sur
physique sur l'attitude sur le sexe sur
une quelconque appartenance quelle
quelle qu'elle soit de ces personnes
on en revient au lien de confiance je
suis le chef du j'espère je met en
oeuvre les dispositifs de sécurité
selon l'analyse de la menace qui est
porté à ma connaissance
selon les habitudes du président la
république selon le contexte et je
recrute les agents qui sont membres de
ce j'espère sur lons les mêmes critères
tout d'abord au simple de professionnels
et ensuite en fonction de mon besoin
bien sûr au sein du j'espère on peut
avoir des profils différents
vous savez pour continuer sur ce que je
dis je dis par rapport aux personnalités
qu'on retrouve dans l'entourage du
président au sein du groupe de sécurité
il ya un agent qu'on appelle dans notre
jargon le siège on appelle le siège
parce qu'ils occupent le siège avant
droit de la voiture du président la
république
son rôle c'est en fait de décharger le
reste
de l'équipe de sécurité des soucis qui
pourraient être ceux du président la
république à savoir le port du manteau
le port du discours le port de la
valette voilà c'est ce genre de
préoccupations qui font que ça pourrait
être un obstacle à l'exercice de la
mission de sécurité donc le siège
il est sélectionné en fonction de
certains critères mais un évacuateur va
être sélectionnés en fonction d'autres
critères
je vais parler de carrie tireur un
tireur opérationnel va aussi être
sélectionnés en fonction d'autres
critères
ça reste des critères professionnels
uniquement professionnelle il n'y a
jamais de pain à mon époque il n'y a
jamais eu d'interférence dans le choix
des agents du j'espère concernant la
sécurité de la famille lorsque le
président de la république était lui
très très très rapidement on fait une
analyse de son environnement familial
pour savoir quel âne menace peu de peser
sur ces les membres de sa famille et
pour proposer au président de la
république
jusqu'à quel niveau de ses proches on va
assurer une protection et de quelle
manière on va l'assurer dont bien
entendu le conjoint
c'est la première des personnes à
laquelle on pense mais ça ne s'arrête
pas là pour ma part les enfants du
président de la république
sa maman était prise en compte par le
gspr et uniquement par le j'espère à ce
moment là on tombe sur des personnalités
qui subissent la sécurité qui subissent
la protection qui souvent ne la
souhaitent pas et et dans ce contexte on
a surtout affaire à des missions dans le
cadre privé rarement dans le cadre
officiel même s'il épouse du président
peut avoir des responsabilités
accompagné le président de la république
ou avoir des déplacements propres qu'ils
soient propres dans lé cadre plus
officiel
donc il n'y a jamais eu quelqu'un
d'autre qui ne soit du j'espère qu'ils
aient appartenu à cette sécurité
mais bien entendu il y avait une
sécurité rapprochée qui détermine et
encore une fois en fonction de l'analyse
de la menace et puis du
de l'accord du président de la
république parce que honnêtement à mon
époque imposé à un enfant une sécurité
rapprochée ça peut être compliqué d un
adolescent avec la vie qui va avec
ça peut être compliqué mais il n'a pas
choisi d'être le fils ou la fille du
président de la république ou du premier
ministre à l'époque
et malheureusement le contexte
aujourd'hui veut qu' on ne peut pas
négliger ces personnes qui à l'évidence
peuvent constituer une cible pour faire
pression sur le président de la
république donc bien sûr si son émission
qui sont prises en compte par le
j'espère et on revient sur le lien de
confiance tout ce qui se passe au sein
de la famille du président la république
doit rester du domaine confidentiel donc
il sait aussi pour cette raison que cela
reste du domaine du j'espère est
uniquement due j'espère je vous remercie
madame di folco
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
préfet dans vos propos j'ai noté que à
votre époque
le gspr était composé de 90 à 100 agents
j'ai noté lors de l'audition du présent
chef du j espère qu un effectif à 76
donc une nette diminution me semble-t-il
savez-vous quand cette diminution a été
opéré et par qui et pourquoi
et j'ai l'impression aussi dans vos
propos que les missions du gspr de votre
époque était plus large que les missions
actuelles ou en tout cas j'ai en tête
formulée différemment
il me semble que la chefferie
actuellement à des missions qui empiète
me semble-t-il sur celle du gspr alors
est ce que le fait que l'émission de la
chefferie a été accentuée voire
peut-être par l'embauché de
collaborateurs supplémentaires provient
du fait qu'il ya eu une diminution des
effectifs officiel j'espère c'est préfet
première partie de l'équipe de la
question c'est le nombre d'agents du
j'espère le nombre d'agents du j'espère
il a été variable selon chaque président
la république s'y regarde si on remonte
à l'époque de jacques chirac s'était on
avait une équipe mixte policiers
gendarmes a acquitté un parité qui je
crois de mémoire était de 60 personnels
mais qui était complété par un groupe
dédié à l'organisation générale des
déplacements du président la république
qui faisait à peu près une quinzaine de
fonctionnaires pour ce qui était du
président de la république nicolas
sarkozy je vous ai donné les critères
j'avais moi souhaité qu'il n'y ait pas
de distinction entre le groupe
d'organisation générale et le groupe de
sécurité du président de la république
puisque pour moi ce sont des missions
qui sont trop proches et c'est une
erreur de les distinguer selon mon
analyse
lorsque françois hollande a été élu
président la république un autre choix a
été fait à nouveau une parité entre
policiers et gendarmes avec un chiffre
qui est allé à la réduction je ne sais
plus de combien
aujourd'hui le chiffre affiché est celui
là celui que vous avez cités en fait je
ne sais pas s'il est exact ou pas jeunes
ou encore une fois j'ai que peu
d'intérêt aujourd'hui pousser ces
notions là ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que le groupe de sécurité du
président la république
on doit lui donner la capacité de
s'entraîner le temps de travail d'un
agent de sécurité de la protection pour
moi lorsqu'il est bien organisé son
décompose en trois temps un temps de
travail un temps d'entraînement et un
temps de repos 6 7 1 3 6 et temps là ne
sont pas respectées
la sécurité ne sera pas bien assurée
quand on n'est pas assez nombreux
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe on empiète sur
le temps d'entraînement
parfois on empiète même sur le temps de
repos ça doit rester exceptionnel ça
peut se produire mais ça doit rester
exceptionnel moi j'ai souhaité que ces
temps là soient respectés par ailleurs
le président de la république lorsque
j'ai eu à m'en occuper avait une famille
sans doute plus nombreuses que les
autres chefs d'état dont je parlais plus
grands un plus grand nombre d'enfants
ce qui s'imposait à moi nécessiter
davantage de fonctionnaires pour pouvoir
assurer cette mission
encore une fois ce chiffre souvent les
médias s'y intéressent de très près
lorsque le président la république est
élu
j'ai du mal à comprendre pourquoi parce
que selon moi il est adapté aux besoins
moi si aujourd'hui le chef du j'espère à
le nombre d'agents de protection
suffisant en nombre c'est lui qui doit
en décider
moi j'ai x évaluer le fait que
cette mission pour être bien accomplie
elle devait être accompli par de 90 à
100 fonctionnaires le chiffre a pu
varier
parce que l'émission ont pu varier
madame jourda merci monsieur prétend
monsieur le préfet vous nous avez
indiqué que la famille du président de
la république bénéficie également d'une
protection rapprochée de la part du
j'espère il peut arriver que cette
famille son conjoint par exemple se
déplace sans le président de la
république
dans ces conditions le j'espère
intervient aussi avez vous vu dans
l'exercice de vos fonctions que la
chefferie de cabinet suivait aussi le
conjoint du président de la république
dans les déplacements ou son conjoint et
sans le président bien sûr tout le
préfet will l'épousé du président de la
république peut avoir des déplacements
qualifié d' officielle sans le président
de la république à titre caritatif dans
des fonctions elle souvent les épouses
des chefs d'état sont invités
donc elles répondent à cette invitation
et son bien invité en tant qu'épouse du
président de la république donc la
chefferie de cabinet peut déléguer
quelqu'un pour gérer le programme qui
sera celui de l'épousé du président de
la république à ce moment là mais on
reste sur des moments que je qualifie d'
officiel même si on est un peu à la
frontière de l'officiel il n'y a pas de
statut de l'épousé du président la
république en france mais ça ça me pose
à nous clairement si je fais un
parallèle avec ce que moi j'ai vécu
aller à un concert c'est pas un moment
officiel mais on peut être invité par
une institution par un hôpital bah voilà
dans des moments plus caritatif il ya ce
moment là c'est les pousses du président
qu'on invite mais à ce moment là bien
sûr il peut y avoir un membre de la
chefferie cabinet parce que tout
simplement il y aura des relations a
organisé avec la préfecture
il y aura des relations avec les médias
organisée il y aura sans doute un
conseil a apporté l épouse du président
quant à la au déroulement de ce
déplacement je vous remercie madame
mercier merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le préfet pour vos propos
pleins de sagesse
ce prêt si expérimenté votre sincérité
et le recul dont vous faites preuve nous
cherchons à cadrer le rôle exact de
monsieur v gala le général bio-farina
nous a expliqué qu'il était un interface
entre l'intérieur et l'extérieur moment
des événements ce qui a été confirmé par
monsieur benalla lui-même en particulier
en donnant une notion d'ambiance est-ce
que lors de vos travaux lorsque six
responsables de la sécurité vous aviez
quelqu'un une personne particulière qui
vous faisait part de l'ambiance qui
régnait lors des évènements et cela vous
semble-t-il important ce préfet il n'y
avait personne de désigner au sein de la
présence la république pour assurer ce
type d'information à mon profit les
capteurs qui mois pour moi été mis en
place mais tu est fourni par les
autorités locales par le préfet
territorialement compétent par le
directeur départemental de la sécurité
publique par le commandant de groupement
de la gendarmerie nationale par toute
autorité locale et à l'étranger de la
même façon voilà je n'ai pas besoin
d'interface le lien existe le lien je
voulais dit le l'agent de sécurité
rapprochée se se place comme un expert
conseiller auprès du préfet ou de
l'ambassadeur qui accueille le
déplacement et donc les échanges se
passe se situe à ce niveau là après les
autres éléments dont on pouvait avoir à
connaître c'est encore une fois
l'analyse de la menace
il ya des services de renseignement
compétent en france kiki qui vous
informe sur le niveau de dangerosité de
risque du déplacement ou hulu de
l'instant pour lequel dans lequel vous
êtes que que pour que vous avez en
charge
je vois pas trop ce rôle interface je
n'imagine pas trop je vous remercie
monsieur waterblez
merci monsieur le président je préfère
si vous aviez constater qu'un
collaborateur ou quelqu'un qui est
proche président lors de ce déplacement
porter une arme auriez-vous c'est
l'objectif prévenu votre ministre de
tutelle le miz l'intérieur attend
personnel alors monsieur le préfet même
si j'avais constaté qu' une personne
était porteuse d'une arme alors que
avançant ça n'avait pas le rôle je n'en
aurai pas rendu compte j'aurai effectué
un contrôle je pense que j'aurai
interpellé la personne ou demander aux
forces locales de vérifier pourquoi cet
individu était porteur d'une arme
mais clairement parce que pour moi armes
égales forces de sécurité intérieure ça
s'arrête là donc si c'est un individu
que je ne connais pas je le fais
contrôler parce que potentiellement pour
moi il est une menace si cette année
individus que je connais je vais m'en
étonner et je vais je pense qu'on aura
une explication
oui parce que la question de monsieur
wattebled quelqu'un qui est proche du
président hu est en déplacement et en
tant que responsable élu président
quelqu'un qui a une ombre et on le sait
on le voit votre rôle et je suis tiff là
c'est pas dans le cas actuel
auriez-vous prévenu l'autorité pour au
moins que ça se sache
bref vous seriez vous opposer à ce qu'un
collaborateur du président de la
république
la compagne en déplacement avec une arme
je m'en serais étonné je pense pas que
je me serais adressé au miso l'intérieur
je pense pas que ce soit du niveau de sa
responsabilité je vais m'en serais
ouvert au chef de cabinet directeur de
cabinet au secrétaire général de la
présidence de la république ça me semble
plus adapté
n'ayant jamais été confronté à cette
situation je peux pas vous en dire
davantage mais voilà c'est pas une
situation à laquelle j'ai été confronté
je vous remercie monsieur segouin merci
monsieur le président ma question était
en partie poser problème monsieur le
préfet non juste pour compléter monsieur
benalla nous a expliqué qu'il avait un
permis pour dames uniquement pour sa
sécurité et rien d'autre donc on peut
considérer qu'il représentait mais il
avait des menaces sur lui et en étendant
le premier cercle du président est de
créer de nouvelles menaces
enfin des menaces supplémentaires
était-il opportun à votre avis de la
voir dans ce premier cercle des préfets
j'ai indiqué que si si pour moi un
membre du cabinet du président de la
république fait l'objet d'une menace là
la solution la plus adaptée si tu lui
affecter une sécurité rapprochée c'est
pas du de données n'a encore une fois la
sécurité est là pour vous enlever les
soucis liés à cette menace et pour que
vous puissiez vous concentrer
exclusivement à votre travail
c'est ma conception de la sécurité c'est
vous enlever ses soucis voilà je ne sais
quoi quoi dire d'autre
et j'ai oublié la fin de votre question
donc fans la fin de ma question c'était
de savoir si vous pouviez agir en tant
que j'espère pour cluny qui ne soit pas
dans le premier cercle puisque
représentait une menace supplémentaire
pour le président mais était-il
indispensable au point de le garder dans
ce premier cercle constitué une menace
supplémentaire non vous savez des
personnes à proximité du président de la
république également menacé il y en a
tout le temps il ya d'autres chefs
d'état étrangers d'autre des membres du
gouvernement français des personnalités
qui bénéficient d'une sécurité
ça ne constitue pas une menace
supplémentaire leur président de la
république que d'être soi même menacé de
se trouver à proximité lui c'est un prêt
à un critère à un critère un paramètre
qu'on prend en compte et qui nécessite
une coordination souvent avec la
sécurité de la personne en question
parce que rarement j'ai été confronté à
jamais j'ai été confronté à quelqu'un
qui se sécuriser par lui-même donc pas
si c'est pas dans ce milieu-là s'est pas
adapté au milieu qui est qu'elle vient
non voilà on peut postuler que quand on
est dans le périmètre du groupe de
sécurité du président de la république
et qu'on est soi-même collaborateurs du
président de la république on est
compris dans la protection qui est
s'applique au président de la république
et à son environnement
on peut on peut postuler enfin on peut
en bénéficier
oui alors je vous remercie nous donnons
toujours la parole aux collègues non
membre de la commission des lois qui ont
qui manifestent de l'intérêt pour cette
commission et je les remercie de leur
présence ce monsieur pierre charon
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
préfet remontons le cours des siècles le
général de gaulle lorsqu'il s'est
déplacé avec un peu un mini j'espère
avec quatre personnes dirigées par le
commissaire paul comiti et il est très
efficace lors de déplacement en bretagne
un jour une pomme est tombé sur le capot
de la déesse noire du général et le soir
le préfet était déplacé vous est il
arrivé dans vos déplacements
pour le président de la république
française nicolas sarkozy d'avoir eu ce
genre de problème
je pense notamment à déplacement dans la
manche où les préfets en charge de la
sécurité n'était pas tout à fait formé
pour faire cette sécurité et d'écouté
pas les conseils de vos précurseur la
manche est un département
particulièrement sur mon cher collègue
et donc je sais pas si cet exemple mais
il ya beaucoup de pommes et peut-être
encore plus qu'en bretagne
alors monsieur le préfet je vois quel
déplacement vous faites référence
j'ai effectivement effectivement eu à
organiser un déplacement dans la manche
dont on peut dire qu'ils étaient
moyennement bien déroulée un savoir que
le président de la république avait eu à
traverser des groupes de manifestants
avec son cortège ce qui en aucune en
aucune façon était une bonne manière
d'agir puisque on aurait dû éviter ces
six lieux les contourner ils n'ont pas
et ne pas espérer que aucun manifestant
ne se jettent sur le véhicule du
président de la république ou
le noeud la grèce ce qui ne s'était pas
ce qui ne s'est heureusement pas passer
il est vrai que les conseils qu'on avait
que j'avais pu que les membres du
j'espère l'époque avait pu prodiguer
n'ont pas été suivis encore une fois
c'est ce que je dis le j'espère le se
porte comme un expert auprès du préfet
territorialement compétent il est le
seul responsable est le seul compétent
décidé de toute décision
je pense que c'est ce jour là un mauvais
choix a été effectué je ne saurais dire
si l'avenir de ce préfet et eliès à ce
déplacement
mais en tout état de cause ce jour là
est pour moi une erreur a été commise
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
préfet de notre expertise et d'avoir
répondu avec précision et de manière
très réfléchie évidemment à toutes les
questions qui vous ont été posées merci